Mexico's capital is home to numerous
iconic monuments commemorating the
country's pre-columbian past and modern
history mingled in with Mexico's
historic memorials however our other
unofficial monuments erected by
activists these anti monuments serve to
remind passers-by of the Mexican
government's mishandling of recent
tragedies the idea of creating anti
monuments is a desperately painful cry
from the population it says our truth is
here it exists and it won't be erased by
the authorities
that's what anti monuments are one of
the most visible anti monuments is
dedicated to 43 students who went
missing from Iguala Mexico in 2013 an
attempted cover-up of the incident by
government officials sparked massive
protests and out of those demonstrations
came this memorial placed right in the
middle of downtown Mexico City Oh Maddie
got SIA a survivor and witness to the
tragedy says the case of the 43 students
remains one of the most emblematic in
recent memory for me this is a reminder
to the authorities who have not solved
the problem after more than five years I
reminded to Mexican society because
cases of forced disappearances number in
the thousands and they should not be
forgotten over the past few years anti
monuments have been popping up near
highly transited areas this one was
placed outside the National Fine Arts
Museum in early 2019 and calls for
action against gender-based violence a
widespread problem in Mexico curiously
enough city officials haven't taken down
these clandestine memorials
legally anti monuments shouldn't be
where they are but it would be a
contradiction to remove them anti
monuments are themselves a former
protest this is a form of expression
outside the Mexican Stock Exchange
another unofficial memorial stands in
plain sight a monument to 65 coal miners
who were killed in 2006 the Mexican
government has until recently refused to
recover the bodies up the road another
sculpture calls attention to 49 children
who were killed in a fire at a
government-run daycare in 2009 to this
day
there's been no accountability over the
incident there are a total of six of
these so-called anti-monitor different
parts of Mexico City this one in front
of the National Social Security offices
for activists and family members of the
memorialized
anti monuments don't only represent
tragedy they're a call for justice
monrad rapido al jazeera Mexico City